C'est une fresque qui a été réalisée
par des lycées et des collèges
de la région du Poitou,
à côté de Poitiers.
Ce n'est pas une fresque
qui vient directement de mon territoire,
mais j'ai trouvé le projet
très intéressant.
C'est une fresque qui est une fresque
en réalité augmentée
et qui parle de l'égalité filles garçons
et qui délivre
un certain nombre de messages
très intéressants sur l'égalité fille-garçon.
Alors je la trouve extraordinaire
parce qu'elle a été faite par des jeunes
qui apportent leur témoignage et en plus,
elle est en réalité augmentée.
C'est à dire qu'avec un téléphone,
vous la scannez
et vous allez avoir des témoignages
qui apparaissent sur les photos.
Je trouve ça plutôt sympa
parce que c'est, j'allais dire un truc,
mais c'est une fresque
qui est pleine de témoignages,
pleine d'empathie
entre des enfants qui parlent de l'égalité
femmes hommes et en même temps,
c'est un objet technologique
que je trouve intéressant
pour permettre de délivrer un certain
nombre de messages sur cette question
d'égalité filles garçons.
Et puis on a voulu
l’avoir cette semaine pour
l'anniversaire de la loi
sur le harcèlement scolaire
qui a 1 an maintenant.
Pourquoi parler d’égalité fille-garçon
autour de cette loi ?
Parce que c'est aussi un des sujets
sur les questions de harcèlement.
C'est parfois des sujets de genre,
parfois des sujets de différences.
Et cette fresque qui explique plein de
choses intéressantes sur cette question.
Donc voilà pourquoi
on a voulu l'avoir ici.
Et puis, eh bien, on est en plein cœur
de l'Assemblée nationale, en plein cœur
de la représentation nationale.
Tout à l'heure, comme
chaque début de séance,
la Présidente de l'Assemblée
est passée devant
et je trouvais le symbole intéressant
de l'avoir ici, tout près de la statue
d'Olympe de Gouges,
pour parler de l'égalité
femmes hommes et d'égalité filles garçons.
Alors aujourd'hui,
par la loi que l'on a fait voter
il y a 1 an maintenant,
on a normalement une obligation
dans chacun des établissements scolaires
de toute la France,
quel que soit le type d'établissement,
d'avoir des plans de prévention
des plans de lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire.
Alors, ça se met en place dans l'éducation
nationale avec le programme pHARe.
Et pour le reste des établissements,
ils ont le choix de mettre en place
le dispositif qu'ils souhaitent.
Mais en tout cas,
maintenant, il est obligatoire
d'avoir dans chaque collège,
dans chaque lycée,
dans chaque école, dans chaque université,
même un plan de prévention
contre le harcèlement scolaire
et universitaire.
Ça, c'est une des avancées de ce texte.
L'autre avancée, c'est l'accompagnement
des victimes et aussi des auteurs.
On parle souvent des victimes, mais
il faut aussi accompagner les auteurs.
Et puis, le troisième volet du texte,
c'est le volet protection,
avec la définition
d'un délit pénal de harcèlement scolaire.
Les étapes, c'est qu'aujourd'hui,
à mon sens, on a aujourd'hui
tous les outils législatifs
pour mener le combat.
Maintenant, il faut que la société
prenne conscience du sujet.
Encore trop souvent, le harcèlement scolaire
est considéré comme des chamailleries entre enfants
comme quelque chose qui n'est pas
très grave, alors que c'est très grave.
Et chaque situation de harcèlement
scolaire peut conduire à des drames.
Les drames, parfois, on les connaît
c’est le suicide de certains enfants.
Mais ça peut aussi être
la déscolarisation,
les difficultés scolaires,
la perte de confiance de l'élève.
Et quand un élève perd confiance
en ses camarades, il perd confiance
en l'institution scolaire.
Quelque part,
il perd confiance aussi en la société.
Et on ne peut pas tolérer ça.
Donc les prochaines étapes,
c'est cette prise de conscience nécessaire
qui doit continuer.
Et puis les moyens,
les moyens supplémentaires
qui doivent être mis
dans chaque établissement
pour parler du sujet,
pour mener ces politiques de prévention,
ces politiques de lutte
et ces politiques d'accompagnement.
Et puis, il y a un grand sujet sur lequel
on doit continuer à travailler.
Et aujourd'hui,
il y a un texte sur ces questions :
c'est l'accompagnement
des mineurs sur le sujet des écrans,
leur l'exposition aux écrans,
l’exposition aux réseaux sociaux,
les bonnes pratiques des réseaux sociaux.
Et puis, j'insiste aussi là dessus
le rôle des parents,
les parents qui doivent accompagner
leur enfant,
accompagner leurs enfants
dans la protection, faire attention à ce
qu'ils regardent, mais aussi accompagner
les enfants dans ce qu'ils disent.
Et les enfants, parfois,
ils sont victimes de harcèlement scolaire,
mais parfois ils sont aussi harceleurs
et les parents ont une responsabilité
de faire très attention
à ce que disent les enfants.
Et donc c'est tout ça
qu'il faut continuer à faire
et c'est un combat qui est important
parce qu'une société où on commence
sa vie sociale dans un milieu hostile, via
le harcèlement,
c’est une société qui n'est pas une société
où on va avancer sereinement
et je pense que ça peut conduire
à des dégâts sur le long terme.
Donc il faut continuer cette lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire d'arrache pied.
Et d'une manière plus générale,
il faut qu'on ait une école
où chaque élève, chaque professeur,
chaque membre de la communauté éducative se sente bien,
se sente dans un milieu apaisé,
dans un milieu où règnent l'empathie,
la sympathie, la bonne camaraderie
entre tous les acteurs.
Et j'espère qu'on va continuer,
enfin “j'espère”,
je suis sûr qu'on va continuer
ce combat et j'espère que ce texte,
qui a maintenant un an, y contribuera.